French prosecutors say a third person
has died and several others are wounded
after a shooting in central Paris Police
say a 69-year-old suspect known to
authorities has been arrested and a
murder investigation is underway
the shooting happened at a Kurdish
Community Center in the city's 10th
Arundel small prosecutors are looking
into possible racist elements to the
attack
so I want to get straight across to our
correspondent Sonia vanakar in Paris
Sonia what more can you tell us about
this shooting
well the shooting took place not far
from the Godless station in Northern
Paris now this is one of the main crane
Stations of the city that's where trains
leave for the East and the area around
it is really crowded and busy very
Lively with with plenty of shops and
restaurants uh and bars and Witnesses
have been describing to the French media
here you know really chaotic scenes and
bursts of gunfire another shooting
reportedly targeted a Kurdish cultural
center but also a hairdresser and a
restaurant the police are investigating
that now the police have detained the
suspect they've recovered the weapon
that was used in the shooting the local
mayor of that district has said that the
suspect was among those injured in the
shooting and has been taken to hospital
and France's interior Mr General Derma
he's on his way to Paris and is expected
to visit the site of the shooting uh
later this afternoon
and can you tell us more about the
suspected shooter what is known about
him
well the reports of the French media
here say that the suspect is a 69 year
old French national now we have no
Clarity yet as to the motive or the
target of that shooting but the Paris
prosecutor's office has opened an
investigation into murder into uh
manslaughter and aggravated violence and
the prosecutor's office says that the
suspect was known to the police and in
fact he was arrested last December after
reportedly attacking a migrant camp in
Paris with a sword the French media have
also been saying that the suspect was
only released from jail just 10 days ago
when he was under judicial monitoring so
I think the questions that will be
raised here now were you know how a
suspect who was under judicial
surveillance got access to a weapon I
think that's one of the quick questions
that will be raised here and it's I
think important to point out that we
still don't have a terrorism charge here
in this case the authorities say they're
still assessing it they're assessing the
events of this morning to see whether
you know the the events occurred word of
a terrorist nature our correspondent
Sonia found a car in Paris with that
developing story thank you so much for
your reporting